Kakophonie auf der politischen Bühne hat
für das Publikum mitunter einen hohen
Unterhaltungswert es sei denn die Lage
ist ernst und das ist sie drohen Energie
Knappheit und damit Mondpreise für Gas
Öl und Strom da wären klare Ansagen und
Geschlossenheit von Bund und Ländern
doch eine feine Sache und im Interesse
der Menschen
Streit und Gaspreis wie viel müssen die
Bürger stemmen jetzt in der Phönix Runde
Phoenix Runde
herzlich Willkommen bei uns meine Gäste
hier im Studio Frau Professorin Monika
Schnitzer ist bei uns
Wirtschaftswissenschaftlerin an der
Ludwig-Maximilian-Universität in München
und Mitglied des Sachverständigenrats zu
Begutachtung der gesamtwirtschaftlichen
Entwicklung auch kurz die fünf
Wirtschaftsweise genannt sie sind also
eine der fünf Wirtschaftsweisen das wenn
Christian Kindler ist
haushaltspolitischer Sprecher der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen im
Bundestag
Mitglied im Bundestag ist ebenfalls den
man Kuban bei der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion sie sind
Wirtschaftsausschuss und wie bekannt
nebenher auch noch Vorsitzender der
Jungen Union und Oliver Stock ist bei
uns Journalist und Herausgeber des
Magazins Markt und Mittelstand so bevor
wir hier loslegen gucken wir uns noch
eine Ereignis des heutigen Tages an
eigentlich war die Sendung ja geplant
für das Treffen von Bund und Ländern zur
Energiekrise der Bundeskanzler ist
leider erkrankt an Corona
nächsten Dienstag findet dann dieses
Treffen statt die ministerpräsidentinnen
und Ministerpräsidentin der Bundesländer
haben sich heute trotzdem getroffen und
verhandelt genau zu diesem Thema diese
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz hat zwei
Vorsitzende den Vorsitzenden Hendrik
wüst aus Nordrhein-Westfalen und seine
Stellvertreterinnen Franziska giffhei
die Regierende Bürgermeisterin von
Berlin und die haben nach der nach dem
Treffen der 16
Chefinnen und Chefs der Länder folgendes
gesagt wir sind uns einig wir brauchen
substanzielle Entlastungen als zentrales
Element dafür haben wir uns verständigt
dass ein energiepreisdeckel für Strom
für Gas und für Wärme kommen muss wenn
wir jetzt nicht investieren um das zu
tun wenn wir jetzt nicht alle Mittel in
die Hand nehmen um das zu tun dann wird
das später uns teuer zu stehen kommen
und noch viel für höhere Kosten
verursachen als das was jetzt im Raum
steht
der Bundeskanzler oder Scholz hat bei
anderer Gelegenheit als es um die
corona-hilfen ging von einer Bazooka
gesprochen die jetzt zum Feuer
freigegeben wird um Schlimmes von
Gesellschaft und Wirtschaft abzuhalten
ist das was da jetzt von den Ländern
gefordert wird auch vor allem dieser
energiepreisdeckel der ja nicht nur Gas
und Strom sondern auch Wärme umfasst ist
das der richtige Weg der Gas ist ja im
wesentlichen Teilen für viele Menschen
eben auch Wärme
nichtsdestotrotz zeigt die
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz von heute
dass sich die Länder einigen können
während die Ampel eben wenig Einigung
erzielt und diese Botschaft geht dann
schon aus von dem Ministerpräsidenten
das und Ministerpräsidentin dass sie
halt sagen wir wollen ein gemeinsamen
Weg wir finden auch über Parteigrenzen
hinweg sie müssen sich überlegen da
sitzt ein Ministerpräsident der Linken
der Grünen sitzt die Grünen sitzen mit
am Tisch die cdu/csu Ministerpräsident
und SPD da ist eine ganz große Breite
und die haben sich geeinigt dass ist
natürlich schon eine gute Leistung das
würde ich mir von der Ampel auch
wünschen
natürlich waren es nicht bei der
Finanzierung noch nicht aber das kann ja
alles noch werden Herr Kindler
wäre der Bundeskanzler jetzt nicht
erkrankt hätte man die Sitzung nicht
vielleicht doch verschieden müssen denn
es fehlen ja noch eine ganze Menge von
klaren Aussagen hätte man da jetzt heute
mit leeren Händen da gestanden was das
Entlastungspaket insgesamt angeht aber
auch vor allem die Finanzierung der
gaspreisbremse
also die Ampel hat ja dieses Jahr drei
entlassungspakete vorgelegt in Höhe von
95 Milliarden Euro davon jetzt das
letzte Paket mit 65 Milliarden Euro ein
Großteil wird der Bund tragen aber die
Erwartung ist natürlich auch der
Bundesregierung in der Koalition im Bund
dass auch die Bundesländer sich an
diesen Kosten dann auch beteiligen das
sind Gesamtaufgabe von Bund und Ländern
die Länder haben insgesamt mehr Steuern
haben als der Bund der Bund nimmt dieses
Jahr große Kredite auf das haben die
Länder bisher nicht gemacht und deswegen
ist natürlich einfach deswegen
Ministerpräsident und Präsidenten sich
darauf einigen dass es ein großes Paket
geben soll und sagen aber nicht wie es
finanziert werden soll meine Vermutung
eines der große nachher der bunter
wieder tragen so dass natürlich einfach
dass sie lernen darauf einigen die
Kommission zur Frage der Gaspreise
Bremse gaspreisdecke Arbeit mit
Hochdruck da wird es bei Ergebnisse
geben klar ist wir brauchen weitere
soziale Entlastung wir werden auch eine
gaspreisbremse oder ein gaspreisdeckel
brauchen und klar ist dass wir das noch
dann zusätzlich finanzieren müssen
Probleme gibt es für die Privathaushalte
aber auch für die Unternehmen Herr Stock
sie warnen ja vor einer die
Industrialisierung im großen Stil
vergleichen das ganze auch mit dem
morgentauplan von
1944 Deutschland ja allerdings auf
anderen Gründen in ein Agrarland
zurückverwandeln sollte was ist denn
jetzt als aus ihrer Sicht als erstes zu
tun um das zu verhindern was sie
befürchten als erstes müssen wir die
Angebote stärken die ganzen
energieangebote die es gibt und die wir
meiner Meinung nach viel zu sehr
vernachlässigen also als da sind
wirklich die Atomkraft sich wieder dazu
zu bekennen Pflaster ist die Kohle zu
optimieren natürlich die Erneuerbaren
voranzubringen natürlich überall Energie
einzukaufen und auch Gas zu sparen aber
die Angebotspolitik die kommt mir viel
zu kurz und die müssen wir erhöhen so
Schnitzer in jeder Krise liegt ja auch
eine Chance immer so schön sagt
worin liegt denn die Chance bei den
aktuellen Problemen die wir haben ich
nenne mal drei Stiche oder die Energie
Abhängigkeit die in der Energiemangel
der sich daraus jetzt ergibt und die
Inflation die ja weite Bereiche der
Wirtschaft und der Gesellschaft erfasst
hat manchmal vor allen Dingen auf die
ersten beiden Punkte eingehen die
Energiepreise sind sehr hoch wir haben
zurzeit nicht Energie und da ist es
natürlich ganz zentral dass man das
Angebot stärkt aber es ist natürlich
auch die Chance darin dass man genau in
die Technologien geht die
Energieträger die wir in Zukunft auch
haben wollen nämlich erneuerbare Energie
und da müsste man einfach jetzt sehr
viel schneller vorankommen um die auszu
und dann auf die Weise das Angebot zu
stärken man kann es dann als Chance
verstehen wenn man dafür sorgt dass man
die Energie die man hat effizient
einsetzt und da zeigen frühere
Erfahrungen beispielsweise dass Beispiel
Japan
fukushima-krise und Subs vorher
Ölpreis Krise in den 70er Jahren dass
man das zu einem Guten wenden kann den
Japan hat sich damals
wegentwickelt von der petruschemie das
war auf einmal sehr teuer ja aber
deswegen haben sie sich nicht die
industrialisiert sondern sie sind in die
Automobilindustrie ganz stark gegangen
in die Consumer Electronics also Kunden
zum Konsum Elektronik da haben sie sich
sehr stark aufgestellt und von daher das
für sich zu einer Chance gemacht
was droht eigentlich
Unternehmen und Verbrauchern im Winter
hat die Politik die Krise im Griff oder
die Krise die Politik im Griff
sowohl Unternehmen als auch für die
Verbraucher gilt können sie sich das
Heizen leisten können Sie sich den Strom
leisten und das bedeutet für die
Unternehmen vor allen Dingen haben sie
die Energie die sie brauchen und
produzieren zu können wir sehen ja jetzt
schon dass einige Unternehmen ihre
Produktion zurückfahren weil für sie das
Gas zu teuer geworden ist denn das was
wir momentan an Minderverbrauch sehen
das liegt ja daran dass jetzt weniger
produziert worden ist und das wird noch
stärker der Fall sein müssen wenn wir
noch weniger Gas haben bzw wenn das Gas
noch teurer wird deswegen ist es so
wichtig Angebot zu stärken also LNG
Flüssiggas zu besorgen und gleichzeitig
auch an anderer Stelle zu sparen da sind
jetzt im Winter vor allem die Haushalte
gefragt momentan konnten wir noch nicht
viel sparen weil wir haben gar nicht
viel verbraucht im Sommer heizt man
nicht also die wenigsten tun das im
Winter ist das jetzt genau die Frage und
da müssen wir auch noch viel mehr Tipps
geben wie man jetzt gut einsparen kann
was muss ich tun damit ich zum Beispiel
die Heizung neu einstellen gucken dass
man sie nicht so lange laufen lässt am
Tag wenn ich außer Haus gehe runter
stellen also was etwa die Hälfte der
bundesdeutschen Bevölkerung heizt der
oder Haushalte weil es mit Gas das
spielt ja in der Industrie eine ganz
wichtige Rolle als Energieträger für die
Produktion deswegen würde ich gerne auf
das Thema gasumlage bzw gaspreisbremse
als erstes kommen weil das glaube ich
auch für die Menschen am
allerwichtigsten ist Herr Kuban da soll
jetzt mal will man jetzt von der
gasumlage abrücken da Falten die Spatzen
hier von den Dächern das alles andere
wenn eine riesen Überraschungen das ist
nicht passieren würde jetzt soll ein
Gast eine gaspreisbremse oder ein Deckel
die Lösung sein ist es die Lösung oder
kann es zumindest das Schlimmste
verhindern was da jetzt geplant ist
gehört ja auch immer die Finanzierung
mit dazu das ist ja ein sehr komplexes
Thema ja wir sehen dass momentan gerade
viele Menschen mit kleinen Einkommen
diese wirklich diese Energiekosten
wirklich an den Rande der Existenz
bringen und die gasumlage ist aus meiner
Sicht unsolidar weil man sich einseitig
auf die Gaskunden sie haben selbst
gesagt nur die Hälfte der Deutschen
heizt mit Gas fokussiert vorher hat man
den Leuten gesagt stellt eure alte
Ölheizung um auf Gasheizung jetzt werden
sie einseitig belastet sie ist
handwerklich schlecht gemacht weil man
lange darüber diskutiert hat wird
Fernwärme einbezogen Ja oder Nein ähm
Mehrwertsteuer drauf ja oder nein und
deswegen sollte sie auf jeden Fall
schnellstmöglich abgelöst werden es gibt
momentan viele Steuereinnahmen über den
groben Daumen kann man sagen bei 10%
Inflation sind es ungefähr
gesamtstaatlich gesehen 100 Milliarden
Euro Steuer Mehreinnahmen die müssen
erst einmal verwandt werden und da
müssen die Entlastung folgen
der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister ihrer Partei
angehört hat ja gerade oder macht ja
gerade ein Gesicht zwar anders
Rückzugsgefecht von dieser gasumlage hin
zu gaspreisbremse warum dauert das
eigentlich alles so lange eigentlich ist
ja
heilige geboten es ist schon relativ
kalt geworden für die Jahreszeit die
Menschen haben ein mulmiges Gefühl dabei
kriegen wir überhaupt
sie haben Briese bekommen von ihren
Versorgern wie wird das mit den haben
wir überhaupt genügend Gas und wenn ja
zu welchen Preisen wieso zögert man da
noch ehrlich gesagt Herr Stock hat das
Angebot hingewiesen wir haben also die
Bundesregierung übernommen haben die
Gasspeicher leer gefunden diese
Gasspeicher wurden von der großen
Koalition 2015 unter Angela Merkel
Sigmar Gabriel an Gazprom verkauft der
größte Gasspeicher in reden wir haben
Firmen verkauft an Russland und der
großen Koalition von Gabriel und Merkel
an Rost nervt so also wir haben ein
Prozent der Gasspeicher die
erfüllt als wir die Regen übernommen
weil sie waren also Faktor leer jetzt
liegen wir über 95 Prozent wir haben
sehr viel Gas in der Zwischenzeit
eingekauft wir haben das größte Paket
für erneuerbaren Energien für den
Sommerpause durch den Bundestag hohe
Gaspreise genau ich will nur sagen woher
kommen die wir haben russischen
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine dadurch
gibt es massive Spekulationen
Verknappung des Angebots und das liegt
nicht daran dass es neue Regierung gibt
sondern es liegt ein Kern am russischen
Angriffskrieg und dann dass er so
abhängig sind von Putins Gas und das ist
leider auch eine Politik von 16 Jahren
Union die wir jetzt mit Hochdruck
versuchen müssen aufzuräumen die
gasumlage soll dazu dienen dass die
Gashändler sowie Juniper die sich
übrigens an Nordsee 2 beteiligt haben
auch das von der großen Koalition
geplant dass die nicht kollabieren wo
mit hunderte Stadtwerke in riesigen
Problemen wären weil die von den
abhängig sind
die geordnet zurückziehen davon
alternative Finanzierung aus dem
Haushalt muss dann bereitgestellt werden
beim Kern ist es so wir werden für
fossiles Gas 250 bis Milliarden Euro pro
Jahr mehr bezahlen müssen wer soll das
bezahlen und deswegen ist der Punkt dass
man darüber reden muss wie der Staat
eingreift wie wir kleine mittlere
Einkommen gezielt entlassen das machen
den Leistungspaketen und was macht das
Schlimmste
entlastet danach haben sie für das
untere lohndrittel nichts getan und dann
die Abmilderung der kalten Progression
gemacht die aber eigentlich erst am 31
40.000 Euro wird da haben sie da haben
sie haben sie nicht entlastet und das
ist
das Thema Zielgenauigkeit spricht gleich
noch mal an
gasumlage noch ganz kurz was sagen ich
will da einiges zu Recht Rücken also es
ist klar die gasumlage ist ist
Vergangenheit das ist einfach politisch
jetzt nicht mehr
opportun die zu behalten aber gefordert
worden ist sie von der Industrie und
warum ist sie gefordert worden man
wollte sie einführen als Juniper
gefährdet war man wollte sie einführen
um dieses um die Versorgung zu
stabilisieren und das hätte eigentlich
den Weg gegeben und das war auch im
energiesicherungsgesetz so 24 es war
eigentlich vorgesehen dass man für die
die noch nicht die hohen Preise zahlen
dass man den den Preis erhöht und dann
haben einige Unternehmen gesagt ja das
könnte jetzt sein dass ich weil ich bei
Juniper bin jetzt einen hohen Preis
zahlen muss ein anderer bei einem
Versorger der noch billiges Gas bekommt
der nicht über diese Pipeline versorgt
wird der kriegt dann noch weiterhin
günstig ist Gas und dann habe ich ein
Problem mit dem Wettbewerb mein
Konkurrent ist besser dran als ich das
heißt die Unternehmen haben es gefordert
und an der Stelle geht es aber über die
Gruppe ausgearbeitet werden
wie gesagt es gibt Ursachen für vieles
Kindler das ja gerade auch genannt wenn
es zu dieser Strom und Gaspreis Bremse
kommen sollte direkt das wirklich zur
Preissenkung bei zum Beispiel auch für
die Unternehmen
es trägt zur Preissenkung bei für die
Verbraucher und dann sind natürlich auch
die Unternehmen darunter was aber zur
Preissenkung beitragen würde viel
stärker und viel dauerhafter ist
wirklich mein Plan also wirklich mal
einen Plan wie man nicht nur Löcher
stoppt wie man nicht nur in den Symptom
herum Doktor sondern wie man im Ganzen
eigentlich in den nächsten Monaten und
Jahren mit diesem Thema
Energieversorgung umgehen will und da
bin ich wieder beim Angebot ich glaube
wenn man so einen Plan in seiner ganzen
Breite entwickelt dann würde der allein
schon wenn man ihnen vorstellt dazu
beitragen dass die Energiepreise
dauerhaft nach unten gehen weil man
sieht okay die wissen was sie tun nur
das kann ich im Moment nirgendwo
erkennen dass einer weiß was auch
schwierig wahrscheinlich in den letzten
Monaten durch die Krisen auf die
Situation sich da in aller Ruhe einen
Plan zu überlegen es gab ja
Vorstellungen auch im Koalitionsvertrag
wie die Umstrukturierung der Energie
stattfinden soll Stichwort erneuerbare
Energie das ist aber eigentlich alles
sehr über den Haufen geworfen stimmt
nicht also wir haben wirklich zehn
gesetzespakete für neu bei Energien vom
sommerlichen Bundestag ist das größte
Paket seit 20 Jahren wir haben diese
Woche ein energiesicherheitsgesetz auf
der Tagesordnung damit werden wir noch
mal neue Kapazität bei bestehenden
Anlagen bei Biomasse bei Wind bei Solar
bei Stromnetzen bringen das hat eine
große Kapazität wir haben die
Gasspeicher bei 95%. wir werden dafür
sorgen und dass wir in diese kurzer Zeit
jetzt auch noch mal den Strommarkt
ändern müssen weil der die Strompreis
gekoppelt sind an die Gaskraftwerke im
Markt was das Problem ist der hohen
Strompreise Strompreise kommen nicht so
aufgrund der Strommenge wir haben genug
Strom exportieren Strom mit viel Länder
auch nach Frankreich das Problem ist die
Koppelung die aber lange Zeit bekannt
war und die eigentlich eine sehr langen
Zeitraum die wir jetzt sehr kurzfristig
machen müssen wir haben extreme Krise
und wir müssen mit Hochdruck das
Aufräumen was 16 Jahre lang einfach
abnehmen
sie braucht eine lange Zeit jetzt muss
ich schnell gehen
Energie müssen sie Windräder in großer
Zahl bauen Solar Dächer bestücken das
dauert alles selbst wenn diese zehn Haar
Regeln und Bayern fallen sollte
zehnfache Abstand Alter Höhe des
Windrades woher sind Sie sicher dass die
ganzen Rohstoffe die man dazu brauchten
das zu bauen so schnell kommen da gibt
es auch lieferkettenprobleme es gibt
viele Rohstoffe nicht die wir oft auch
gar nicht mehr im Moment nicht bezahlen
können Fachkräftemangel bei der
Installation dieser Gerät das wird doch
fünf sechs sieben acht Jahre dauern
derzeit muss es ja irgendeine schneller
gehen wir haben die Planungszeitraum
deutlich zu verkürzen wir haben massive
planungsbeschleunigen jetzt bei
Neubaugebiet vorgesehen noch mal wir
werden diese Woche alleine in mehrere
Gigawatt Kapazität neu ans Netz bringen
aber bestehenden Anlagen den wir Deckel
wegnehmen die es bisher gab durch die
alte Regierung und so die Kapazität
deutlich entschleunigen und trotzdem
können wir nicht das alles aufräumen was
Angela Merkel 16 lagen sie ihre
Regierung einfach versenkt habe das kann
doch keiner sein
jetzt ganz ehrlich im Bereich der im
Bereich der Wärme waren sie es doch die
gesagt haben lng-ports wollen sie nicht
bauen hat haben die Grünen bis heute
einen Beschluss für jetzt sich als
Könige der dritten Halbzeit hinzustellen
und zu erzählen was alles irgendwie
schief gelaufen ist obwohl man selbst
das gewesen ist die noch in den ersten
Papieren der neuen Ampelkoalition gesagt
haben wir wollen mehr Gaskraftwerke
bauen sie wollten keine lng-ports bauen
sie haben genauso aufs Thema Gasgesetz
als Übergangstechnologie wenn man aus
Atom und Kohle aussteigt wie wir das
auch getan haben und ehrlicherweise auch
beim Ausbau der Erneuerbaren wenn man
sich das anguckt das Verbandsklagerecht
das gerade bei uns in Niedersachsen drei
Windkraftanlagen nicht gebaut werden
können wäre es OVG das beschlossen hat
durch ein Verband ein
umweltschutzverband der aus München
geklagt hat das keine Erfindung der CDU
genauso wenig wie die
artenschutzvorgaben wie oft der Rotmilan
schon eine schon ein Windrad in
Deutschland verhindert hat das sind
artenschutzvorgaben die sie immer
wollten als grüne die wollten wir nicht
und deswegen und deswegen können sie
sich dann nicht aus der Verantwortung
ziehen gucken sich doch mal an was der
grüne Ministerpräsident in
Baden-Württemberg gemacht hat der ist
bei Top 13 Prozent erneuerbarem Strom
den er produziert während wir in
Niedersachsen schon mal über 50 aus der
Verantwortung sondern wir haben ja
konkrete Regelung jetzt vorgelegt im
letzten halben Jahr die genau für viele
Probleme die es bisher gab angehen vor
allem die Abstandsregelungen sind
Riesenprobleme auf die 10h-regelungen
Bayern hingewiesen vielen anderen
unionsgeführten Ländern haben wir das
auch dass wir massive Abstände nein NRW
hat mir das zum Beispiel ganz lange und
dann das schwarz-gelben Landesregierung
wo wir massiv große Abstände zum
Beispiel hatten und das ist richtig das
über erneuerbare und den Ausbau reden
das ist das ist völlig in Ordnung aber
es reicht nicht ich glaube das ist das
zweite Grundproblem auf der einen Seite
das was sie alle vorhin angesprochen
haben lange auf das billige Gas auf
Russland gesetzt das war ein
Kardinalfehler der zweite Kardinalfehler
ist zu glauben dass wir mit Erneuerbaren
wirklich den Primärenergiebedarf in den
nächsten Jahren decken können wir sind
glaube ich bei 17% im Moment das ist
noch ein riesen Abstand bis zu dem Ziel
wo wir alle hinwollen deswegen das wird
in der Tat mehr als fünf bis acht ich
würde gerne bewegen uns jetzt gerade
zwischen Vergangenheit 16 Jahre ihrer
Merkel und Zukunft wann wird die neue
erneuerbare Energie der führende
Energielieferant sein ich würde gerne
die Gegenwart zurückkehren zum Thema
Energiekrise wie kommen wir über den
Winter das ist glaube ich von Herrn
Kuban vorhin schon mal angesprochen die
Frage der Zielgenauigkeit der
Unterstützungsmaßnahmen der
Entlastungsmaßnahmen ist da mehr soziale
Differenzierung nötig als das was bisher
stattfindet das ist ja das
Gießkannenprinzip jeder bekommt die
gleich viel Entlastung ob es jetzt
wirklich dringend benötigt oder nicht so
dringend benötigt muss da noch
nachgebessert werden also das muss man
sicherlich die Frage ist nur wie einfach
ist es das zu tun was man wirklich gerne
machen würde ist die Menschen zu
entlasten die es wirklich nötig haben
das heißt die am Ende des Monats kein
Einkommen übrig haben und die auch
nichts auf der hohen Kante haben indem
Sie jetzt die höheren
[Musik]
Wärmekosten die hören Heizungskosten
bezahlen können die genau zu erreichen
ist aber nicht so einfach denn wir haben
nicht von allen Personen eine
Kontonummer plus die Informationen was
verdienen die denn plus die
Informationen wie heizen die und
dementsprechend wie belastet die sehen
das haben wir einfach nicht und
dementsprechend kann man das nicht
machen jetzt kann man versuchen sich zu
behelfen indem man beispielsweise den
Gaspreis deckelt ja aber dann
profitieren auch alle die wir hier
sitzen und ich hoffe wir erzählen jetzt
nicht zu diesem unteren Drittel würde
ich jedenfalls mal vermuten und das ist
eigentlich nicht richtig an der Stelle
muss man sich dann fragen wie sammelt
man das wieder ein eine andere Variante
war ja das hat man beim energiegeld man
gibt pauschal den Menschen etwas und das
muss dann versteuert werden dann hat man
zumindest eine gewisse Kompensation
dafür die einen müssen wenig Steuern
zahlen weil sie verdienen nämlich die
anderen mehr eine ganz andere Variante
wäre zu sagen okay jetzt können wir es
nicht so Ziel genau machen dann machen
wir aber an einer anderen Stelle den
sozialen Ausgleich dadurch dass wir
sagen das ganze muss ja finanziert
werden wie finanzieren wir es zum
Beispiel durch einen energie-soli der
von den der der ähnlich wie der
Solidaritätszuschlag den wir nach der
nach der Wende eingeführt haben den
Abhängigkeit von der Einkommensteuer
bezahlt wird ein bestimmter Prozentsatz
und das heißt die mit höherem Einkommen
müssten mehr dazu beitragen das für eine
begrenzte Zeit beispielsweise für zwei
Jahre um zu sagen durch diese Krise
müssen wir gemeinsam kommen wir sind als
Land Arm
ärmer geworden durch diese hohen
Energiepreise einige können das
Schultern die sollten das dann auch tun
für diese begrenzte Zeit das heißt
Christian Lindner wenn das führt
möglicherweise Pickel bekommen die Frage
ist gab ja schon
eine vermögensreichensteuer gibt oder
vielleicht auch eine übergewinnsteuer
alles ineinander gescheitert sind ich
würde gerne bei dieser Zielgenauigkeit
wie man das jetzt auf den
unternehmerischen Bereich überträgt
Stock
ist das auch nicht viel genau genug
kriegen da auch Unternehmen Geld ist
eigentlich nicht nötig haben und die die
es eigentlich mündlich haben vor allem
die kleinen mittleren Unternehmen die
schauen da ziemlich durch die Röhre ist
da wieder zu viel Geld ja durchs
gießkannten Prinzip unsinnig vergossen
also zunächst mal ist das scheinbar
passiert als man versuchte Juniper zu
retten und dann diese gasumlage sehr
Ziel ungenau geplant war aber das ist ja
jetzt Schnee von gestern was ich aus dem
Betrieben höre ist dass es wirklich
große Not gibt dass viele sie sagten als
Frau Schnitzer die Produktion
runterfahren und wenn Gasproduktion oder
durch gasbedingte Produktion
runtergefahren wird das geht nicht mal
eben sondern dann werden die wenn die
Maschinen kalt die kann man dann nicht
in der nächsten Schicht wieder anfangen
das heißt das sind richtige
Unterbrechungen und ich glaube dass
diese diese Betriebsunterbrechung die
Produktionsunterbrechung die führen am
Ende zu starken Belastungen der Betriebe
und dann auch zu ganz starken
Belastungen der Menschen die in diesem
Betrieben arbeiten also meine Prognose
ist das werden kurzarbeiterproblem in
den nächsten Monaten bekommen werden
eben weil diese Betriebe ausfallen und
diese Entlastung stärker auf die
Wirtschaft und auf den Mittelstand zu
fokussieren ich glaube das ist noch eine
Hausaufgabe die ansteht
eine kurze Anmerkung also bei den
kleinen Einkommen die wird einfach wenig
Steuern gezahlt die kann ich fast nicht
über Steuern Entlastungen entlasten und
deswegen kann ich sie nur über
Direktzahlungen entlasten das ist
einfach Fakt und diejenigen haben sie in
dem Paket vergessen sie haben die
wohngeld-empfänger entlastet und danach
die Abmeldung der kalten Progression wir
haben in Deutschland ein
Durchschnittseinkommen von 38.000 €. und
sie wissen besser als ich dass die kalte
Progression wirklich erst anfängt zu
wirken ab 35 40.000 €. ordnungspolitisch
bin ich sehr dafür dass wir die kalte
Progression abschaffen und die Frage ist
ob es jetzt gerade darum gehen muss
Leute mit so hohen Einkommen wie wir
sitzen oder muss es nicht erstmal um
andere gehen die müssen Vorrang haben da
bin ich sogar richtig verstanden habe
dass sie eigentlich ein Plädoyer für den
energie-soli hier ich finde
normalerweise erstmal das eine tun bevor
man das andere wenn man jetzt die
Entlastung durch Direktzahlungen machen
kann dass man arbeiten
abzuzweigen die Steuern zahlen die viel
Steuern zahlen dass man sagt oder besser
gesagt die viel verdienen dass man sagt
ein energiesole ist da das war ja ein
Szenario ist genau das Richtige um zu
diesem Ausgleich zu kommen zu einer zu
einem sozialen Ausgleich und
gleichzeitig aber auch zu einer
Finanzierungsquelle damit die Schulden
nicht anders gemacht sind aber dass man
einen 9 Euro Ticket für jeden macht 300
Euro energiegeld für jeden macht man
macht einen Tankrabatt für jeden und da
sage ich Ihnen ganz offen und ehrlich
Leute die so viel verdienen wie wir die
brauchen keinen neuen euro-ticket die
brauchen keinen Tank Rabatt und die
brauchen auch keine 300 Euro energiegeld
und wenn diese entlastungspakete weiter
so laufen dann wird es auch keine
Akzeptanz dafür geben in der Bevölkerung
hat massive Steuersenkung gefordert als
entlastungspakete übrigens
Mehrwertsteuersenkung auch massive
steuersenken verbesser verdienende hat
auch wieder keine Senkung wird ja vorher
noch diejenige
redet die keine Progression haben sie
gefordert als Union als sie
verteilungswirkende unionsprogramme
werden noch schnell also deutlich Schle
ist das was jetzt durch die Ampel
vorgelegt ist nämlich deutlich schon
besser verdienen gegangen von dem Kern
haben wir die energiepreispauschalen
entlastet wo es viele Menschen mit einem
mittleren Einkommen und kleinen
Einkommen Griff wir haben das während
des Kindergeld deutlich erhöhen wir
werden soziales Bürgergeld einführen
während das Wohngeld deutlich ausweiten
wir werden noch mal jetzt studieren und
Rentner entlassen werden sehr viel auch
für kleine mittlere Einkommen in diesen
Paketen tun und ich finde man sollte das
nicht klein reden was da gemacht ist und
die Union hat bisher ehrlich gesagt
keine besseren Vorstellungen vom Tisch
gelegt also mit dem Tanker
war ich auch nicht glücklich und ich
finde auch wir können über höhere
Beiträge auch von besser verdienen hohen
Vermögen dieser Krise auch reden
drauf und die Erfahrung zeigt eine
Steuer einzuführen geht relativ zügig
aber sie wieder abzuschaffen dauert
Jahrzehnte Beispiel solidaritätsbetrag
ich habe gerade mal geguckt ich zahl dir
noch immer ich dachte das ist
abgeschafft also
das ist
natürlich noch leisten so wie wir von
der aber trotzdem funktioniert seit
Jahrzehnten und er ist eben immer noch
nicht weg meine Befürchtung wäre so
schön dieser Vorschlag ist in zwei
Jahren darauf zu verzichten das wird
wieder nichts das ist das Problem wenn
man erstmal wenn eine Aufgabe wegfällt
ja dann müsste diese müsste sozusagen
der auch wegfallen für alle weil
ansonsten kann man auch einfach für die
Reichen die Steuer erhöhen das wäre dann
die ehrliche Antwort aber nicht zu sagen
man macht es nur für 95 Prozent die
Abschaffung des Solidaritätszuschlages
entweder die Aufgabe ist weggefallen
oder sie ist eben nicht weggefallen für
die obersten fünf Prozent höhere Steuern
zu machen also wir sind dafür wir werden
dazu bereit wenn die Union dazu bereit
auch im Bundesrat aber man kann doch
nicht immer nach höheren Steuern rufen
wenn man auf der anderen Seite nicht
alle Möglichkeiten und jetzt komme ich
wieder auf das Thema zurück alle
Möglichkeiten ausgeschöpft hat das
Angebot zu stärken und möglicherweise
auf die Art und Weise zumindestens ein
Großteil dessen abzufedern was uns jetzt
zusätzlich ansonsten belastet aber
trotzdem noch mal vor Augen führen wir
sind als Land ärmer geworden wir
importieren sehr teuer die Energie das
heißt als Land sind wir einmal geworden
davon verdienen jetzt andere Putin aber
auch USA alle die die uns jetzt Gas
liefern wir als Land sind ärmer geworden
einige können das nicht leisten die
anderen müssen es leisten das heißt
irgendwo muss das jetzt gerade
übertragen werden und das muss man auch
so ehrlich sagen wir können nicht so tun
als ob sich die Welt nicht verändert
hätte das heißt am Ende muss jemand die
Rechnung zahlen und wir können natürlich
das über Schulden machen dann sahen uns
unsere Kinder und in gewissem Umfang
müssen wir das wahrscheinlich auch tun
oder wir müssen uns überlegen wer sonst
soll es zahlen was können nur die
Reichen aber
mit seinem angebotsschock wir haben ein
angebotsschock und ich ein Angebot
Schock das wissen sie besser als ich
dann muss ich vor allem das Angebot
erhöhen und wenn ich mir jetzt anschaue
nehmen wir das Thema AKW in Lingen das
Kernkraftwerk in Lingen das wird jetzt
abgeschaltet daneben direkt daneben
steht ein Gaskraftwerk das wird dann
hochgefahren das ist doch dann am Ende
das doch am Ende keine solide Politik
genauso wenig wie am Ende sich als
Schiffen ölkraftwerk vor die Küste der
Nordsee zu stellen um die Netzstabilität
zu erhalten das ist doch am Ende keine
Erhöhung des Angebots
fährt und häufig gewinnkraftwerke
abgeriegelt werden weil nämlich die
Grundlast dann erneuerbaren Strom bei
Wind verdrängt also das Problem
ja aus Niedersachsen stammen und der
Wahlkampf ist dieses Thema gerne ich
wollte gerade schon Lob aussprechen dass
sie so lange still gehalten haben damit
wir sprechen das noch an in den nächsten
15 Minuten ich würde gerne noch einen
Stichwort von ihnen aufnehmen und zwar
wir sind irgendwie ärmer geworden oder
das Land ist einmal geworden es gibt ja
eine ganze Reihe von Ursachen für die
multiplen Krisen der
Überfall auf die Ukraine war sozusagen
der Brandbeschleuniger der Krise gewesen
es sind Sanktionen ausgesprochen worden
massive Hilfe für die Ukraine ist nötig
dieses
ärmer werden ist das der Preis der
Freiheit ist das der Preis den alle auch
oder jedenfalls bezahlen können
Unternehmen Privatleute Privathaushalte
Unternehmen muss man das vielleicht noch
mal sich in Erinnerung rufen woher das
alles kommt dass das nicht alles wie
unvorhergesehen vom Himmel gefallen ist
ja wir befinden uns in einem
Wirtschaftskrieg und das Problem bei
einem Wirtschaftskrieg ist dass alle
verlieren den kann man nicht gewinnen
sondern der Wirtschaftskrieg blockiert
den Handel wenn der Handel blockiert ist
dann leiden beide und das ist die
Situation in der wir gerade stecken und
sie wird jetzt nicht so weit gehen wie
Sahra Wagenknecht die gesagt hat der
Wirtschaftskrieg sei von Westen
ausgelöst worden nein natürlich ist sie
nicht vom Westen ausgelöst worden
sondern der ist die Antwort des Westens
auf den Überfall auf die Ukraine nur
verlieren werden wir Ihnen garantiert in
der einen oder anderen Art und Weise und
insofern ja das ist der Preis den wir
dafür zahlen und wir haben hier glaube
ich im Konsens dass wir diesen Preis
irgendwie aufbringen müssen und jetzt
müssen wir ihnen gut verteilen man
könnte auch ganz anders mal denken und
können Sie sagen okay so wie eine NATO
ein ein eine Unterstützungsleistung von
verschiedenen Ländern ist bei einem
Angriff könnte man auch in einem
Wirtschaftskrieg sagen gut Deutschland
ist davon schwer betroffen jetzt müssten
wir eigentlich für eine Solidarität auch
von den anderen westlichen Partnern ein
uns in diesem Wirtschaftskrieg zu helfen
lange davor gewarnt dass wir auf
nordstream 2 setzen die haben gesagt ihr
macht euch geopolitisch strategisch
abhängig vom Putins Gas die sind zu
Recht sehr verärgert über Deutschlands
agieren in den letzten Jahren und es ist
ja nicht so dass es keine Warnung gab
das für uns geostatiges ja einseitig von
Putins Gas abhängig gemacht haben wir
haben das mehrfach im Bundestag als
Fraktion nach und Opposition
angesprochen und es ist nicht vom Himmel
gefallen und dass wir auch ehrlich
gesagt bei der Gebäudesanierung so
schlecht sind dass wir so viel Häuser
die nicht gut gedämmt sind liegt auch
daran dass wir viel zu lange hohe
Standards also zu geringe Standards
hatten bei der Dämmung beim Neubau so
und das ist schon das was man hätte in
der Vergangenheit angreifen aber eine
Finanzierungsfrage auch sind und die
Standard werden wir jetzt deutlich
erhöhen wir haben massiven Umschichtung
jetzt zu Gebäudesanierung was extrem gut
läuft und die Energieeffizienz Programm
müssen wir weiter stärken weil das jede
Kilowattstunde die wir dort einsparen
extrem sinnvoll ist um natürlich dann zu
machen
bei nordstream zweites und Einzel
Stichwort waren da gibt es ja allen
mutmaßliche Angriffe jetzt auf diese
Gasleitung genau weiß man nicht was
dahinter steckt die sogenannte sensible
und verwundbare Infrastruktur
Energieinfrastruktur ist ja nicht nur in
der Ostsee verlegt sondern auch in der
Nordsee wo wir ja jeden Tag und zwar ein
Großteil unseres Gases herbekommen
offshore von der Nordsee und aus
Norwegen Frau Professorin Schnitzer was
wird eigentlich passieren wenn dort auch
so etwas auftreten würde dass die
Gasversorgung in diesen sensiblen
Punkten unterbrochen wird was bedeutet
das dann für das für der Gaspreis durch
die Decke gehen was was muss man da
eigentlich befürchten also er würde auf
jeden Fall noch mal weiter steigen er
steigt ja jetzt schon obwohl wir jetzt
aus nordstream 1 oder nordstream 2
überhaupt kein Gas bezogen haben in der
letzten Zeit um einfach wegen der
Unsicherheit weil die Unsicherheit noch
mal größer geworden ist jetzt an der
Stelle dann zu sagen jetzt wollen wir
doch bitte mal die Solidarität der
anderen europäischen Länder einzufordern
dass
kann man wollen das kann man auch
versuchen aber man sollte da schon sehr
diplomatisch vorgehen denn man muss doch
sagen in den bisherigen Krisen war es
immer so dass wir uns hingestellt haben
und zu den anderen europäischen Ländern
gesagt haben ihr habt euch bisher
wirtschaftspolitisch nicht gut
aufgestellt an euch an euch liegt es
dass wenn ihr eure Krise hatten dass wir
eine Finanzkrise hatten all solche
Themen und man hat da gerne den
Schulmeister gespielt und gesagt ihr
müsst euch jetzt mal zusammenreißen und
wir sagen euch wie es besser geht also
von daher muss man jetzt schon etwas
aufpassen oder sagen wir mal so es ist
auch irgendwo verständlich wenn die
anderen jetzt denken na ja jetzt sehen
wir mal dass ihr auch nicht alles
richtig gemacht habt und jetzt wollte
unsere Solidarität also bitte in Zukunft
vielleicht ein anderer Ton
beim Thema Preis Energiepreise durch die
Decke gehen sie haben es mehrfach
erwähnt ist dass Energieangebot wichtig
die Verbreiterung womit wir jetzt beim
Leib und magenthema von Herrn Kindler
und Herrn kubans sind nämlich der Frage
ob man die Atomkraftwerke die Atomkraft
weiter in dieses Energieangebot
zusätzlich einfließen lassen soll der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister hat gestern in
der Fraktionssitzung bei ihnen ja gesagt
es soll zu diesem streckbetrieb kommen
das jetzt fast schon ein Beschluss
ungefähr für drei Monate ich glaube in
in
bei Isar 2 geht es nur zweieinhalb
Monate ist das jetzt die Lösung
überbrückt dass die den Energiemangel
den wir im Winter haben dass wir eben
einen Teil des Stroms eben durch die
Verlängerung der Atomkraftwerke
einigermaßen sicher haben
ich bin kein großer Fan der Atomkraft
und ich glaube auch nicht dass man die
Probleme von morgen mit den Technologien
von gestern löst und deswegen kann es
nur darum gehen für eine Übergangszeit
jetzt die Atomkraftwerke länger laufen
zu lassen und dafür zu sorgen dass man
das Netz stabil hält dass wir nicht
weiter zu viel Gas verstromen denn das
findet leider immer noch statt das Gas
verstromt wird und es wird das ganze
Problem nicht lösen ich sage aber auch
sehr selbstkritisch in Richtung meiner
eigenen Partei wir können nicht auf der
einen Seite von den Grünen verlangen
dass sie Gaskraft dass sie
Atomkraftwerke länger laufen lassen dass
Kohlekraftwerke hochgefahren werden da
ist auch noch Potenzial sind der ist
zwei von 25 Kohlekraftwerken wieder
hochgefahren worden und gleichzeitig
aber eben auf der anderen Seite beim
Thema Windkraft im Wald bei der Frage
von Abstandsregelung oder ähnlichen auf
alten Dingen beharren sondern da braucht
es am Ende einen großen Energiekonsens
auch zwischen den demokratischen
Parteien und aus meiner Sicht braucht es
eben die Atomkraft jetzt für eine kurze
aber be ganze Zeit wie wird das
eigentlich jetzt in ihrer Partei
diskutiert nicht nur in der Fraktion sie
haben noch ein Parteitag im Oktober da
letzten einige offenbar schon die Messer
das ist schon für viele ein Rückschlag
gewesen denn man hat ja unterstelle ich
jetzt mal etwas
zugespitzt vielleicht für den 31.12
dieses Jahres schon durchaus den Sekt
kaltgestellt nicht nur weil Silvester
ist sondern weil eben der Atomausstieg
dann endgültig beschlossene Sache ist
jetzt wird sich das weiter verzögern es
gibt ja in ihrer Koalition von der FDP
zum Beispiel auch die Forderung das zwar
auch nur noch als Übergangslösung zu
betrachten aber eben wesentlich länger
als diese drei Monate im Jahr 2024 war
glaube ich die Rede wie gehen sie denn
jetzt mit dieser Situation um sowohl
innerparteilich aber auch in der
Koalition es zählt ja wenn ich das
richtig verstanden habe jede
Kilowattstunde man muss sich glaube ich
die Situation genau angucken welcher
Krise wir sind wenn eine massiven
Gaskrise wir haben hohe Strompreise
aufgrund der Kopplung an die
Gaskraftwerke im stromagdesign das muss
jetzt schnell geändert werden was aber
sehr kompliziert ist das hat man auch
nicht reinreden wir haben aber keinen
strommmengenproblem gegen gewinnen immer
noch Strom Exporteur so europaweit so
von daher geht es eigentlich im Kern und
die Atomkraftwerke bei der
Atomkraftwerke im Süden werden nur sehr
ein geringen Beitrag haben zu
Netzstabilität wenn wir uns angucken das
überlasst Management deutlich mehr auch
in solchen Krisen irgendwie ein
Netzstabilität erreicht werden kann es
gibt im Spitzenlasten eine besonders
belasteten Tagen wenige Tage im Winter
wenn wir uns angucken dass wir jetzt in
der Höhe von zwei AKWs diese Wochen
Bundestag neu erneuerbare Kapazität an
den Markt bringen also über Biogas bei
Solar bei Wind sehen wir dass wir auch
andere Alternativen haben wir haben
gesagt und der Bundeswirtschaftsminister
hat einen Vorschlag gemacht für eine
Notfallreserve wenn es massive Probleme
gibt in vielen Fällen und wir sehen dass
es in Frankreich gerade weil die
Atomkraftwerke so schrottig sind und
weil die Klimakrise auch zum Beispiel
massiv die Probleme noch verschärft
durch Dürre und durch Kühlung dass wir
das die Situation genau anschauen werden
das werden wir machen im Herbst wir
gehen jetzt ins ordentlich
Gesetzgebungsverfahren werden die
Kriterien definieren und dann uns im
Winter im November und Dezember genau
anschauen ob wir dieses Notfallreserve
ziehen müssen aber im Kern wird das kein
großer Beitrag sein so oder so
dass die AKWs in Frankreich so grottig
wären heute stand heute morgen ich habe
mal nachgeschaut liefert Frankreich
Atomstrom nach Deutschland zwei Gigawatt
nach Italien 2,5 Gigawatt und in die
Schweiz 1,8 Gigawatt also dass da alles
so grottig wäre das finde ich das habe
ich eine der Gründe für die weiter für
die Weiterführung Risikotechnologie und
wir sehen das einfach massive
Sicherheitsprobleme in Frankreich sind
es gibt ja zwei Gründe für die
Fortführung einmal das die
Stromversorgung Frankreichs und eben die
Netzstabilität Sie angesprochen haben
Christian Kindler ja vorhin gesagt das
dritte AKW in Lingen liegt ja
in Niedersachsen wie gesagt 9 Oktober
Landtagswahl wenn man Hinweis von mir
das sei gar nicht für die für die
Netzstabilität wenn ich Sie richtig
verstanden habe
nicht gebraucht wird das ist ja auch ein
Wahlkampfthema in Niedersachsen
kann man dann guten Gewissens auf dieses
Atomkraftwerk verzichten braucht man es
dann doch nicht allerdings fehlt mir ein
bisschen der glaube wenn ich dann höre
dass die Bundesregierung plant das
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium ein
Schiffen des ölkraftwerk zur
Netzstabilität an die Küste der Nordsee
zu stellen liegen ist von der Nordsee
120 km entfernt Das ist da ist viel
Strom ja aber am Ende will man jetzt zu
Netzstabilität Vorschlag des
Bundeswirtschaftsministeriums das dort
hinstellen ich habe den den Chef der
bundesnetzagenturen Müller auch ein
grüner gefragt und er hat gesagt er
möchte sich dazu besser nicht äußern er
verweist auf das
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium ich glaube
dass da nicht so ganz mit offenen Karten
gespielt wird ich finde bei dem ganzen
Thema und
das Glück nicht den Politiker spielen zu
müssen und ein Kompromiss zu suchen
haben wir vor ja nach Fukushima in
Sonderweg eingeschlagen und das
Erstaunliche ist ja sie haben vorhin das
Beispiel Japan erwähnt dass in Japan die
Atomkraft wieder eingeschaltet worden
ist und Japan nach wie vor darauf setzt
ich glaube dieser Sonderweg hat dazu
geführt dass wir die ganze Technik
vernachlässigt haben natürlich hat
keiner mehr investiert natürlich hatten
sie mir jetzt nicht mehr gesagt wir
machen da weiter und wir stehen jetzt da
wo möglicherweise neue Technologien in
dieser Richtung uns weiterhelfen würden
wir die aber nicht mehr haben deswegen
dieser Ausstiegsbeschluss 15 Jahre
später ist man schlauer das war ein
Fehler
also in Frankreich hat ja immer auf
atomkerung selbst die sind jetzt massiv
in der Misere weil ich die Klimakrise
einfach die Sicherheitsprobleme sich
massiv verschärfen die Kühlung sich
verschärft und die Sicherheitsprobleme
durch die Überprüfungen die wir übrigens
bei Isa 2 Neckarwestheim seit 13 Jahren
nicht mehr gemacht haben also die
periodisch Sicherheitsüberprüfung die in
ganzer großer Tests machen 13 Jahren
nicht mehr die haben die in Frankreich
haben die gerade Testungen gemacht und
sehen dass es massive
Sicherheitsprobleme gibt und Frankreich
hat ein massives Stromproblem und ist
jetzt wirklich richtig tief drin also
das ist irgendwie kann ich überhaupt
nicht verstehen man hat aber auch an
anderer Stelle Investitionen
vernachlässigt denn was zum Atomausstieg
gehört hätte wäre in die Stromtrassen zu
investieren so dass man die Windenergie
vom Norden in den Süden bekommt und da
schauen wir uns jetzt mal nach Bayern
werfen wir mal den Blick nach Bayern da
hat man sich lange erstmal dagegen
gewehrt dass diese Stromtrassen gebaut
werden und dann hat man sie irgendwann
gebaut und wollte sie aber dann
unterirdisch verlegen sodass es sehr
viel länger dauert und also mit dem
geplanten Atomausstieg zum Ende des
Jahres dietras nicht fertig sind es
fehlt also an der Stelle für die gesamte
Netzstruktur auch an Investitionen und
da hat man viel zu spät angefangen auf
die Erneuerbaren wirklich einzugehen
möglicherweise eine politische
Fehlentscheidung der damaligen
csu-staatsregierung gewesen
Ministerpräsident sind auch nicht viel
besser aus wir haben ich wollte aber
nochmals angesprochen haben können wir
schon die Antwort auf meine Frage
gegeben die ich eigentlich stellen
wollte nämlich die technologische
Weiterentwicklung effizienzschub für die
Wirtschaft sie haben auch die Ölpreis
oder die Ölkrise von 1973 angesprochen
dann wurden
spritsparende Motoren gebaut und so
weiter aber wo kommt dieses Geld jetzt
für diese effizientshop her da muss ja
massiv in Technologie investiert werden
wir haben viel müssen viel Geld auch für
Maßnahmen zur sozialen Absicherung
ausgeben ist das für diesen
effizienzschub den Sie sich jetzt
erhoffen durch diese Krise überhaupt
genügend Investitions sind überhaupt
genügend private und öffentliche
Investitionsmittel da das muss man ja
erstmal anschauen wie es bei sein
Unternehmen aussieht und es gibt ja
durchaus Unternehmen die auch in der
Krise noch sehr viel Geld verdient haben
es ist nicht so dass alle Unternehmen
kurz vor der Pleite stehen würden das
gilt für insbesondere manche
Mittelständler das gilt möglicherweise
für größere Unternehmen dass sie
jetzt kein Geschäftsmodell mehr haben
wenn die Energiepreise dauerhaft hoch
sind aber das gilt nicht für alle
Unternehmen das heißt es gibt durchaus
Unternehmen die jetzt dieses Geld hätten
und die Unternehmen die es jetzt nicht
haben aber investieren müssen den muss
man natürlich helfen wie macht man das
indem man entweder Kredite zur Verfügung
stellt oder indem man konkret das
subventioniert oder unterstützt was an
diesen Investitionen notwendig ist also
nicht einfach Regenschirm jetzt für alle
Unternehmen sondern sagen okay wir
unterstützen euch wenn ihr es schafft
mit diesem Geld euch so besser
aufzustellen dass sie tatsächlich eine
Zukunft habt auch wenn wir bei aber da
gebe ich Ihnen
Energiepreisen haben letzte Woche Demo
der Bäcker in Hannover ich weiß nicht ob
sie auch da gewesen sind ich war da wenn
dann Bäckermeister mir erzählt wir haben
letztes Jahr
360.000 Euro Energiekosten gehabt und
planen im nächsten Jahr mit 1,4
Millionen da fragt er sich wieder noch
seine Brötchen verkaufen soll der kann
nicht sein Brötchen also das heißt Preis
erhöht und wenn er mit zu diesem höheren
Preis ist und wenn er zu diesem höheren
Preis einer Semmel noch verkauft seine
Brötchen dann wird er sie verkaufen wenn
er sie nicht verkauft hätte zukünftig 9
Euro das ist nicht wahr denn diese
Energiekosten sind ja nur ein Bruchteil
dessen was da reingeht bei der
Bäckereien genauso das heißt also die
können tatsächlich Rohstoffe sind nicht
auch gestiegen die sind genauso
gestiegen in Hannover besucht und Kern
sind die Energiekosten nicht das
Hauptproblem der Bäcker Vielfaches im
Personal so und wir erhöhen und die wird
nach der Nacht also wir werden auf jeden
Fall besser
daneben helfen der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister hat ein
Programm aufgelegt dazu finde ich gerade
eine Abstimmung davon ist die
Finanzierung des Bundesfinanzminister
sichergestellt sein wir werden konkret
Bäckereien in KMU auch Energiekosten
Dämpfung helfen das ist klar für die
Bäckereien sind Energiekosten das habe
ich Probleme das habe ich kein habe ich
nicht gesagt ich habe gesagt dass ich
das Hauptproblem sondern es gibt viele
Fachkräftemangel und der nachfrageschock
den wir haben die Frage ist ja Frau
Schütze hat gesagt können auch die
Preise zum Teil überrollt werden auch in
der Woche weitergegeben werden das heißt
die gezielte Stützung kleinen Mitteln
Einkommen ist zentral wichtig und eine
Politik die eben auch dafür sorgt dass
Kundinnen und Kunden nicht total jetzt
ins sparen reingehen sondern Kern auch
noch mal Möglichkeiten haben
freundlich mir noch das Stichwort zu
geben für meine Abschlussfrage die ich
natürlich vorformuliert habe nämlich war
ja heute schon ein Thema die ist jetzt
von allen gefragt wird das Gelingen im
Winter werden wir auch mit Solidarität
über diesen Winter kommen was meinen Sie
wir haben noch 30 Sekunden die müssten
Sie sich jetzt durch vier Teilen wenn
ihnen was einfällt
die Politik gefordert nämlich das Land
zusammenzuhalten und das nicht jeweils
zu nutzen um Parteipolitik zu betreiben
dass ich in einem Wahlkampf verständlich
aber in einer Krisensituation eben nicht
genau wir brauchen eine große
Krafteinstellung von Bund und Ländern
gemeinsam hin Zuversicht dass das die
demokratische Parteien auch gemeinsam
hinkriegen werden
diejenigen die besonders stark betroffen
sind entlasten dann werden wir es
schaffen so eine rentarität von den
Verbrauchern und von Betrieben
einzufordern ich meine das muss er die
Politik Stimmen ich bedanke mich bei
Monika Schnitzer bei Sven Christian
Kindler bei Thielmann Kuban und bei
Oliver Stock liebe Zuschauer morgen in
der Phoenix Runde der Kampf der Frauen
wankt das Mula Regime im Iran jetzt
folgt Phoenix der Tag mit Mark
Steinhäuser darin noch einmal die
Konferenz der ministerpräsidentinnen und
Ministerpräsidenten hier in Berlin heute
mit den Äußerungen etwas ausführlicher
als hier in der phoenix-
[Musik]